big moment of truth let's see if nick
has actually seen any improvement from
the past half hour spent training in vr
i've been playing a lot of virtual
reality lately i actually really enjoy
playing vr though it's kind of in its
infancy stage right now but i have a
theory playing shooting games in vr
shooting range games gun games etc i
think it actually makes people a better
shot in real life generally speaking
you're doing the same motion the same
hand-eye coordination granted the
mechanics are a little bit different
compared to using a real gun but i'm
curious i'm going to test the theory
that practicing your marksmanship in vr
can make you a better shot in real life
so today we set up a course that
somewhat replicates a shooting range in
one of the vr games that i play hot dogs
horseshoes and hand grenades we have
cans in the front here and four targets
hanging here in the back we're going to
set a timer and you have 17 shots just
like with the real glock hit the four
cans in the front and the four targets
in the back we would go down to the
shooting range and test this with a real
gun except for the fact that youtube
basically demonetizes any videos showing
real firearms so in this case we have to
use an airsoft gun granted the mechanics
are a little bit different but the
hand-eye coordination and accuracy tends
to be about the same so we're gonna do a
little test in the shooting range here
to measure our baseline performance and
we'll see how much we improve after
training in virtual reality for about
half an hour i am a little more
experienced in firing firearms whereas
nick over here
hello
it's a little less experienced come back
out and we'll do the test again
obviously
science
got my shooting glasses on
tactical i think this makes you like
five percent better range is hot and
three
two
one
wait is it stop watch
wait
it was on time right take two three two
one start
[Applause]
done 10 seconds pretty damn solid it's
not too bad and i did how many shots
here we have
three left 14 shots 10 seconds i'm
nervous now
start with your gun down three two one
start
[Applause]
all right all 17. we're all sixteen and
a half seconds roughly you actually got
pretty good at the end there adrian will
also be our baseline of somebody who
doesn't train so nick and i will be
trading in vr we'll gauge adrian's
performance here and agent's performance
at the end to see if he improves just
from simply doing the test out here and
not going into vr three two one start
man
nice so you actually never hit that
first cam i didn't no but you got eleven
fifty how many babies you have left none
adrian's timing was a lot better his
accuracy is about the same as nick's
nick how often do you go shooting at
most a couple times a year and do you
play airsoft at all play vr at all i
don't play vr at all and airsoft i used
airsoft a ton but i haven't touched an
airsoft gun for about seven years
okay cool let's go do some training
we're running this vr setup we're gonna
be using this prevail pro sent to us by
pny there's actually a workstation
laptop i've never had a workstation
laptop before the reason we're using
this is because vr is very demanding on
your system you're basically cranking
out 90 frames per second 2k resolution
per eye or something like that i can't
remember basically you're cranking up a
bunch of pixels and you need a computer
that can keep up for a long time i never
really knew the difference between
workstations and like just regular
computers but i did some research turns
out that workstation graphics cards are
actually intended for really high
precision stuff cad modeling or
architecture modeling you need things to
be very precise gpus aside the rest of
the computer here's what i love about
this thing there's a port for every
freaking cable on the side so you got
your display ports you got your usbc's
you got your usb 3.0 we got your hdmi oh
and that's just not one side we got the
other side we got we got your ethernet
so we got your sd card readers we got
another usb 3.0 because you need a lot
of those ports you got headphone jacks
you got microphone jacks this ain't no
macbook pro i feel way more fluid
actually yeah i think it's really just a
reflex thing like you get used to like
how much you need to move the gun each
time plus i'm better at vr now
i could barely hold the gun all right
nick how you feeling feeling good man
i'm feeling tactical
feeling
stronger sitting in my brain i think
it's gonna work
i don't know let's find out
big moment of truth let's see if nick
has actually seen any improvement from
the past half hour spent training in vr
so the gun down so the gun down here we
go three two one go
nice dang son that was took me really
dang good no that took you 11.7 seconds
okay your last one was 16.3 yeah and you
still have rounds how many rounds you
got left oh i have one chamber and then
i have four so five five runs left 12
shots 11.7 seconds compared to nick's
old 16.3 seconds and 17 shots with one
target missed well maybe maybe i should
go and see if i can fix it and three two
one start
[Applause]
nice nice dude
that feels good 7.25 nice that's really
good really good also i have six rounds
left okay
all right that's an improvement that
felt really really solid actually i
could feel a lot more like locked in
like when i moved and like looking down
the sides of the gun and having it still
staying like like i'd be here and then
move and rather than everything shifting
it would all move together it's all
about that like locking it in
and just moving your body as a whole
that's what i learned in vr at least
adrian didn't train in vr let's see
start
[Music]
that's it 9.2 how many chassis left
that's a lot better dude those cans
yeah four for four dude one two three
four five
yeah it's just i think you just need to
like get a feel for the gun yeah i think
the reality is just doing this three
times in a row makes you better so
here's what i think we learned
vr can definitely help your coordination
and give you just a little more sense of
how the whole thing handles real life
still has certainly way more variables
vr is only giving you one small part of
the puzzle but it is a part of the
puzzle and you can't improve that one
piece of the puzzle with vr i would
definitely agree with that man i felt
way more comfortable so vr definitely
isn't as good as probably training in
real life oh yeah definitely if you went
to the range shot a box of rounds
went home trained like legitimately
trained in vr not just shot the targets
like made a point of trying to like hold
the same form and like doing some
discipline and then you went back to
range you would definitely see a little
bit of an improvement oh yeah yeah your
accuracy will get better there's
mechanics like pulling the trigger and
causing the gun to jump and flinching of
the gun jumps and all those kind of
things that takes practice with an
actual firearm on an actual range in
terms of like that hand-eye coordination
that instinct shooting of just pointing
the gun in the right spot every time vr
can definitely help with that oh yeah i
totally agree yeah so tell
your parents that video games are
actually good for you
like that mom and dad do you want me to
be good with a gun mom come on